1800 here we go
65 players 1874 average rating time
handicap
let's roll got the little ticker in
place already Sicilian why did I do that
okay I should have done that only at is
that pond really gonna be taken okay
clean here my pond are they gonna really
I don't know I don't want a castle
actually let's open up the B file can
they get it the B file here okay
what I want to be next Aipom gonna fall
what's that King doing I'm gonna take
that pawn they haven't they could have
taken it while ago just block and then
hit that Queen give a check here oh I
should have just taken the Queen ah
she's bound to file she might be trapped
I have a lot of activity a lot of
activity might resign are they gonna
resign you have that Bishop where's the
meat making to threat a threat on c1
difficult to defend you can't really
defend it that's not defending back
determine to a lot of two's okay 28
minutes remaining the soldier soldiers
here 28 minutes 35 seconds to be exact
okay here no matter what
all right so make sure that that guy is
out before I play e6
all right so point A to point B I think
that pawn capture should not have
occurred until I had moved my dark
square bishop okay captured towards the
center I'm okay with double pawns over
here
okay let's hit this guy maybe I maybe I
just want to trade dark scribe bishops
yeah their Bishop is better than mine my
queen has a good post all right now I'm
gonna try this I'm gonna try this now
this is a hole also this is a weak point
so Bishop here Queen takes pawn might be
available if the knight move now I want
to get my knight here which is a really
really good square devastating square is
picking up material can't be defended by
the knight and there's three heavy
pieces or three pieces of much greater
value than the night okay the queen and
the king but yeah knight Knight g3 this
is going to be a killer 21 seconds not a
good defense
grab the rook next maybe the pawn on fs1
a Castle queenside now throw my rook
here grab this pot no do this let me hit
this Knight and then I think I didn't I
was forgetting the knight or just go
there or Willie check and now this pawn
is dead you know that pawn is dead
Knight here where there's a potential
fork okay on push not afraid of anything
okay now pawn push is ready to happen
pawn takes okay they're just down at
time I lost track of it twelve six six
four cap is there again I think there's
a much greater possibility of us two
getting paired up this time not as many
players 77 players at this point hang on
let's stop that b5 okay they still went
with that they're dropping this though
and they're dropping that so I'm up with
full rook psych sure just taking the
bishop now I got it
now I got it whoa that is a problem my
rook is close to dead though isn't he oh
man my poem is throwing the fort of the
fire Manning what are they doing
kitchen sink back to tournament 1212
they reside in 1212
eight six it's pretty quick here we go a
lot of time remaining 25 25 minutes
remaining this is just getting started
just getting started okay at night okay
well let me try something sneaky maybe
this pond could be a giant thorn let's
just let's just do that is that pond
really gonna be taken huh Knight right
here oh no I'm fearful okay look
oh let me give a check pawn push might
be needed yeah it's gonna have to be
played I should just take the bishop I
could get a rook and a queen yeah that
was the way to go now I'll take care I
have this square covered just get rid of
that pesky night get rid of that pesky
pesky Knight pin this Knight pawn push
next it's just brutal my bishop getting
here is gonna hit everything I was like
that night in that that one game getting
to g3 now it's f3 devastating 20 2017 12
24 minutes Rocky mr. Balboa gotta play
against Rocky Balboa here not the guy
you want to see ever
ever okay I was saying that about the
mayor in that last term I wasn't that
okay I really don't know what I'm saying
pawn push get to f7 undermine this
structure somehow here we go it's
undermined for sure
no it's gonna crumble I hope can I get
at this point
let's take that [ __ ] up take you at the
check the queens are gonna come out or
are they where's the meet right here
make that happen
yeah all right I don't know what it
would lead to I'm just not sure what it
would lead to okay um let's support my
night don't let him go anywhere so fast
now that Knight is dead he's a dead duck
King up no matter what
grab this pawn and then get my bishop by
the way and push my pass pon my bishops
are really good here connected passed
pawns keep these guys connected just
drop back probably no matter what I play
here and then just push my pawns I could
just take that pawn if he pushes get
this guy there I could give a check
actually this is close to me oh it's
gonna be in the pen why did I just take
that not gonna take pin pieces king over
and it's made on b8 that's made back to
tournament 30 30 30 20
Anton squared is right there at third
the chief Peter Griffin the chest chief
Oh 9 it was all about my fishing stuff
oh hang on Siberian ok hang on Siberian
stuff I'm still gonna go here can you
pick up that dark square bishop backup
knight here was a possibility let's try
this it's not really gonna be taken I'll
take this now
get here on that dark square and then
take on g3 it's that night up to I can't
be good can it that's with the check I
could grab this this pawn with check and
I'm afraid let's do this
not sure why huh oh no my queen is was
close to dead I think my knight should
have played here or something
okay now I'll go there get my Bishop on
this diagonal pawn push also I have a
lot of good possibilities here I'm just
gonna take that I don't I don't want to
deal with that let's check just drop
back here now it's my rook even doing
let's get him doing something where's
the mate threatened mate oh this is
difficult to defend oh that's me back to
tournament forty two thirty thirty
I think the bishop had to go to h3 I
have a slight cushion right here but we
saw what happened we saw what happened
and I had like a 30 point lead in that
that tournament that last tournament and
it evaporated in a blink in a blink so
twelve points is nothing is what I'm
getting at clean here and then get out
of sneaky stuff with c4 I keep that guy
around actually
okay Knight move is gonna be a bit
annoying I think okay pawn push I'm not
afraid of a key throw my knight in to c4
just take like this this is an issue now
those pawns are separated my other night
getting here would be nice trade darks
for a bishops take with my queen she's
gonna be really well placed in the
center of the board finally get my rook
working I should've just taken that pawn
take him now pawn push next f5
should have been considering this
earlier my clean I don't know that she'd
be kicked away Queen trade potential all
right this is fine him up upon and
there's tactical issues we're not
tactical issues but just pawn issues
everything is hit these guys are
vulnerable pawn push this could be a
thorn getting to f6 back rank mates it's
got a flight square right here I opened
up my second rank but this is fine I
want to get to this light square towards
the center give it a check okay let's
just do this and I'm gonna do this no
matter what this game is not gonna
finish back determine down on time 56 42
42 less than 20 minutes remaining
here we go um okay especially cough I
don't even know all right I'm fine with
this I am fine with this setup like okay
that Bishop is hit twice they're really
gonna castle they shouldn't get this
[ __ ] I've opened up the a file on that
Bishop twice on that pawn twice let's
trade just a little bit now if they
missed that could have taken h2 as well
now everything is falling on push if I
took the knight then there is gonna be
an issue with the g7 so I'm okay with
these ponds being messed up hitting the
night and he's not moving my pawn is a
thorn my Bishop wants to be right here
and then looking for made on the back on
the first rank
let's grab here first here probably no
matter what Queen trade and then soon
enough of rook trade let me make sure
however that I have a flight square and
I do and I think I want to do this
actually to me pawn push with this grab
this pawn everything is defended just
have to watch out for stalemate I'm not
gonna even take that that's me back to
tournament 72 whoa whoa you see what I'm
talking about cap is up there step 72
the chief again it's not a
Oh back to term and he resigned to hang
on I'm ahead eighty-one 72-54 cap is
back cap is back 17 minutes remaining
hmm a lot of time not even at the
halfway point I'm gonna drop that there
we go otherwise the night gets pushed
around if you don't take I insist I
don't want to move first you move first
now I got this pawn I should have taken
it I guess so this pawn is dead
all right let's just take here and then
get this Center stopped the night from
pivoting here maybe I should have
defended that night no for them to give
up their light square bishop they're
crazy are they crazy let's see about
that take this way towards the center
let's have a good reason not to I want
to keep this pawn here it boxes out the
night cleanup eliminate their
LightSquared bishop get on this open
file look a here purposeful Bishop here
and then get my knight okay well this is
this is an issue I want my knight needs
to do something other than just stare it
upon he's just staring at pawns right
now I was ready to drop stuff I think
moving my knight and stuff Oh what's
what's happening here oh they get it
back somehow
no they don't okay I'm Jeff that was
just a freebie that was a free pawn
support my night flight square for my
king all right just push here everything
is defended oh there goes the Queen just
like that don't blink do not blink
okay don't blink
that pond will be tracked down so this
but this a pond is ready to rumble back
to chairman Thor down on time 101 90
okay we could get paired up any second
are you nervous I'm nervous that's
always a tense game in my heart races
it races okay
sometimes my knight will voluntarily
take that my bishop will voluntarily
take that night but not now I was since
I was provoked
now it's I'll just what I'll do
it's threatened me that's what I'll do
for right now I could grab this if I
took it my queen I think she gets
trapped or something Bishop d6 I don't
know it's just open stuff up now now
I'll do it
take this bishop can't get here okay I'm
on that twice it could take here and
really take I'm on the clean oh I'm on
the queen that hurts that definitely
hurts they resigned back to tournament
110 110 Oh 121 110 it didn't register
yet those who are looking at those
numbers you just got Jude just like me I
was not the only one who was wondering
what the who was keeping track of the
math hang on why does my night going why
is he going here okay this night
what's this queen up to she's scaring me
for one she's definitely scaring me I'm
gonna take this play here and go here
that's not like a plan
sound like a plan bishop c6 and pawn
push here we go ready hit the queen with
interest everything is falling but I
don't want to take care of seven would
have killed me you're gonna grab here
though or are they oh oh the Knights are
creeping in creepy crawlers I have this
covered now what a mane right here let
me let me castle for one I'm gonna take
here I could have taken that make it one
threat free be thirty seconds remaining
that's me back to tournament 140 hang on
150 cap is up there 150 141
oh man haha Rooker Rooker here we go
everybody's been playing the Sicilian
against me it seems in this tournament a
few Sicilians this guy gonna move this
could be good he's at negative six maybe
had a problem with his isp the stakes
have been doubled back the tournament
that's a quick 20 you have to move
within 15 seconds or you go down it
resigns it for you right away
another quick resigner oh I'm getting
showered with points I have a little
slight cushion which could be evaporated
in a second if I play against camp if I
don't win or if I lose it goes back I go
back too and he goes up 20 which is
putting him in first place before you
know it 13 minutes remaining okay my
Knights getting chased around but it's
okay it's okay he's gonna get chased
around again I'm not so okay with that
one cuz my light squares are now ripped
apart no they're not I don't think you
should have allowed I think my opponent
should have done that is something gonna
happen with this pawn push I'm not
afraid of it I'm afraid of that Knight
though
Queen e1 can I get this pawn he he has
to go a number one priority this guy you
have to go definitely he's just doing
too much he's taking away flight squares
for my king more long-term he's
overextended right now there is no pawn
push there is this pawn push though my
knight wants to be here there
LightSquared Bishop is dead to the game
pawn push is not working now my knight
is doing good what am i what do I want
to do as a follow up I'm not so sure
pawn push might be available let's get
out of attacks I don't even know what
I'm doing I don't even know what I'm
doing my knight wants to go somewhere
else clean trade get my Knight to c4 I
don't I want to have this square
available no I like my knight too much
let's try something else
yeah what am i doing what is that what
am I even doing
okay I'm winning a piece now my Kings
gonna be fine right here let's challenge
this rook right now my doctoral Bishop
wants to do something else I promise
he's gonna do something out soon pivot
on this square so I could get a passed
pawn when I pivot there did that make
sense why just sit here
what are you saying man
what are you saying what are you even
saying this guy is down on time okay
upon his past he is a past pun they
resigned back to tournament 191 190
I'm pretty sure it's just between us too
huh there's a pretty good gap there
between second and third pair me up 1111
let less than 11 minutes
this guy's negative 16 oh I thought he
might be one of those 15 second rule 15
second rule guys you know what I mean
you know what I mean
why did I do that there's no Bishop on
b5 I'm seeing things now seeing things
okay Bishop b7 Bishop e7 get in d5 if
the pawn flinches then I get to f5 it's
one of the differences between you
having the knight on e7 opposed to f6 as
soon as this pawn flinches I could good
I could jump in there
my opponent gonna move with their Knight
he doesn't have much choice I guess
going home was the other one okay now I
need to get castles since the e-file is
opened up just take that take with my
knight so I could get my bishop oh you
got castle but if the rook place to eat
one after the exchange on c6 I play
Bishop e7 otherwise Bishop d6 let's see
hang on
oh I'm dropping this pawn I'm gonna
queenside castle let's defend that pawn
push eventually I play Bishop c5 with
check yeah it definitely should be
queenside castling I think
all right I don't know I don't know
let's teach strong word definitely okay
I definitely want to go here okay don't
allow the night to get here you gotta go
you have to go there's no time I take
that anything doesn't matter back
determine to 11 to 10 oh my goodness
this is so tight nine nine minutes
Romania are we gonna get paired up oh
man is it gonna be ten Scandinavian
player Wow what's going on with this
I'll take that pun Bishop c4 that comes
with check I think I want to take
another pawn take another pawn and then
what's this night up to scaring me he
has all these pieces it's this in the oh
you got it looking for me right here
stop that
oh I could take the night on my clean I
don't know if that was the best but I'm
okay with trading I'm up I was up
material anyhow okay I'm gonna take my
rook oh oh I have this move for a while
didn't I the Knight has to give itself
up and then it didn't here no matter
what where does that mean they resigned
back determine 250 whoa 250 to 3100 I
thought it was playing against him I
might need to do that we I might it
might be the case that I need to get
paired up against him in order to
somehow overcome that lead okay secure
my night position get my Bishop out next
okay let's do this stop the knight from
getting in here jump in here III is
where I want to be in just in
I'm covering this actually my night was
there my bishop is also here I don't
know if I want a job I'd rather jump in
as soon as the bishop moves I should
have done it now I'll do it next time
no a night here actually this is this is
appealing one night here the other one
here my queen on b6 pawn push I could
control here maybe there's me maybe I
could work maybe I couldn't I want to do
this now clean here pawn push next I
still want to get my knight into that
square kick this night away and then
pawn push open up the light square this
pond is hit twice okay I should have
taken that rook I want to take it now
and I have a fork right here it's
probably been there for a while okay I'm
when I'm winning a lot of material right
now are they gonna resign okay don't
take that my queen was in a pin on the
bishop now I'll take it push this pawn
keep pushing my pawn on this night twice
after takes you're gonna take times off
back to chairman 290 oh my goodness 290
even if we get paired up how can i oh my
goodness how could I overcome that the
answers these questions okay okay hang
on let's do this get into f5 I need some
quick kills where are they
I'm on that square can't defend like
this I do a push and now this this is
dropping with the devastating effect oh
he went that way he went that way didn't
he
Castle it's this Queen up to the knight
can't move because I've the pressure I
have on the bishop now that the Queen
went where she is looking at this point
was moving these two pawns my knight
here
that's a freebie I'm controlling this
now Bishop here I do my knight on c4 and
everything is defended pawn push okay
looking I just want to make sure that
there's no issue no issue get out of
this diagonal and now let's take here oh
I had that defendant I had that one
defendant now I could defend like that
and then from my knight in here 445 okay
alright where is the Queen check really
just rook here next here mate in 1 2 3
there we go back to Turman to 70 to 90
hang on did he drop back or something or
is he playing a game if he if he loses 1
or something I could have a chance I
think I'd still need to get paired up
against him 4 minutes remaining
4 minutes remaining
for a minute warning a lot of pawn moves
ok is that not gonna be taken I don't
know why captured like I did there okay
I don't want to take that night I don't
think let's see now I have to take them
I need to get these pawns working my
knight is almost dead my Knights know
it's a good home now get my pawns
working keep these auto that pawn push
is gonna kill me my opponent is oh I
have that move
Wow
and throw this check in I don't know
yeah let's take that I guess and gotta
open this up
oh that ponds gonna take okay hang on
capture this pond this is very very
difficult very very difficult
where are the mates oh my goodness I
think I need to go for a perpetual or
something can I get this
there's no checks against my king this
might work
is it gonna work where's the main that's
no that's not mean I don't have anything
oh my goodness I don't have any good
checks huh oh my goodness I thought I
had made I don't have mein ah man what
am I missing
ah my goodness I don't have anything ah
man I'm dead let me hit the resign
button I'm dead I'm down on time as well
and he's at 310 ah man
ah why'd I go with d4 this is the last
game could I have even caught him no but
I'm gonna look too I'm gonna start to
say oh well even if I won so it doesn't
matter am I the only one that does that
well the only one who else does it raise
your hand who else admit it okay there's
no way I could be the only one there's
no way here we go
trade dark square Bishop jump in here
Bishop takes Bishop I jump in here with
check first and say you can't castle
hang on that's your that's the hold your
horses variation mate where is it it's
not me
okay I need to get castled and let's
pile up on this guy 37 37 can I at least
get this last one in there I'm not sure
what that's doing okay let's grab a pawn
queen trade get rid of that night it's
too tricky 30 30 30 30 one minute
remaining on the bishop in this pond I
don't want to take it just yet now I'll
take it cuz if it's hit I back up and
defend my pawn take with my king it's no
problem
defend this pawn it looks silly but I
want to March my pawn here keep marching
stay coordinated I'm push again he's
defended he is defended keep pushing
there's 22 21 seconds
I hear real care next I'm gonna take I'm
gonna take that pun oh they're calm the
tournament game aborted they didn't let
me get that one I don't follow me at 8
seconds I think they caught a little
soon ah wouldn't matter what if 3:30 my
goodness
uh okay let me do the math I went back
to instead of going up to what I want
even got to 300 my goodness
okay good games oh wow 332 69 197 chef
tournament